hello reject nation
so whatever space we occupy in youtube
everyone in that space is covering the
mandalorian season two finale and we
were actually gonna shoot that
right now but when jon was on his way
over here
something popped up in the notification
bells and i said
whatever you do do not go to the
notification bells now our mandalorian
reactions
all go up on saturday i already know the
comment boxes are like where's your
mandalorian reaction i got
text messages about like what are you
gonna like people this is the first time
people text me so i know it's a big deal
it'll be up tomorrow but this had to be
covered
first and john seriously has no idea
what i'm about to pull up
in the notification bell something
popped up on ign called
i am jesus christ
and i was like okay a jesus christ movie
cool i click on it
i watch the first like eight seconds and
then i realize this is a jesus christ
video game what
wait what whoa whoa whoa i only saw the
first eight seconds
it's jesus christ video game and it's
first person
point of view like okay mandalore is
going to have to wait just uh
just a tiny bit so we can cover this
trailer
and then immediately just give all our
undivided attention to the rest of the
day
to making sure we can get mando up at a
proper time we gotta watch this
[Music]
in the beginning was the word and the
word was with god
and the word was god
he was with god in the beginning
through him all things were made
without him nothing was made that has
been made
in him was
[Music]
this looks like a griffith observatory
movie
something you would see on a class field
of so many thoughts there were
their flocks shepherds this is
everything i've wanted
joseph a well-rendered hut
available on steam kickstarter
oh oh dude all the money you would have
given at the church collection just give
it to this kickstarter
when this pulled up i went to the
description box and i was like
is this what i think it is and so here's
the description
check out the latest trailer for the
upcoming pc simulator
and i am jesus christ players will
interact with a cast of over
60 biblical characters and perform
over 30 miracles including feeding the
masses
and resurrecting the dead wow now
look we grew up catholic that's how we
met the first 10 years
[Laughter]
i have a lot of catholic friends i have
a lot of very
my closest friends are christian i have
some friends who are mormons so i by no
means
am dogging on the religion okay i'm not
but this shit's hilarious
so like holy sh holy [ __ ]
it is hilarious look at it right now
when we're watching it
25 000 views 2.2 kid likes 587 dislikes
why whatever
right away you do this game people will
you know people will not
either people who are anti-christian or
people who are a christian
exactly it's like wow that's really
that's controversial then when i watched
this channel its entirety i was
surprised by how
moving it was and how it seemed so
genuine and sincere in its intentions
i'm like it looks cool and but it's also
like
really funny it's gotta be curious i
mean i really
am i'm part of me is thinking what are
the game mechanics i mean am i just
gonna have to hit a certain number of
letters and numbers to to do a miracle
or is there gonna be some kind of you
know
is it gonna incorporate without the
graphical power some of those like oh
you gotta like talk to the characters
and sort of do it that way like a story
game i don't know this gave me the charm
of like a low budget bible movie in that
sense of like it's probably aiming to
teach you
a little bit about the scriptures and
whatever and you know
use the video game format to engage with
people who might not be
reading a bible so you're playing as
these other bible characters which i
think you'd be
like there's a version of that that
sounds so cool absolutely like if you
could play as like david versus goliath
or something
yes first person rock shooter
but this is uh i am jesus christ from
what it sounds like is you play as jesus
at some point in here
and it says right here resurrecting the
resurrecting the dead feeding the masses
what is feeding the masses exactly how
are you how are you feeding
what is the feeding how is that a fun
part you'll find out the true story via
side quest of how jesus multiplied all
those loaves of bread and fish if this
game is a success
what will the sequel be will it be
inspired by let's say the passion of the
christ
you know will you go through the
stations of the cross
in a follow-up game and meet over 50
important figures to that horrible time
in jesus's life
like once i read the description my mind
just started racing with questions
yeah it's laughs hopes
aspiration the possibilities are
absolutely endless and it seems
so damn well intentioned yeah that i'm
like
the only let's play i've ever done on
this channel was for a game called
hatred and i think it would be great if
i just did a complete warning
scales with the next game the most
malevolent game and the most benevolent
game he has an
indie game where you get to play as
jesus christ
how great would that be and if this does
well enough think of it they could make
a sequel with a way bigger budget make
it an open
sandbox world you can just explore all
of galilee and nazareth
and just go through every biblical story
as a quest equestria cyclist
i mean how do you lose in the game do
you die you've got a
lever counter up at the top and if it
falls below a certain number of
believers you disappear who are the
villains
do you fight the fight race are gonna
has it become assassin's creed ever
is it philistines assassins the romans
roman soldiers you occasionally have to
fight with just
parables and arguments for things at one
point you just go in and flip
tables over to earn points but it seems
like
the kind of game if this game is pulled
off well let's say you know you are
someone who goes like catholic school or
you want your kids to learn more about
christianity and like those christian
movies those faith-based films
make so much they seem like they just
fly under the radar but also make
a gazillion dollars at the box office
right
i never hear about them they just make
so much money on streaming rentals and
when the theaters are open box office in
terms of wanting your kids to
maybe get a little bit more educated
this seems like a good step
the assassin's creed of bible cases like
it could work this is what i mean
i have all thoughts with this yeah i
have this sounds silly and hilarious
this sounds like this could be very
effective and educational
and it also sounds like it can go
extremely right at the same time
exactly that's why i just had to cover
this i'm like this will distract my mind
i need to talk about this game yeah now
i just fund that kickstarter because i
absolutely want to know what the
experience of play like can you do it in
vr
that's what i mean if you could do this
in vr how how great would you if you
could be
jesus christ that would be the ultimate
experience
and then watch it glitch out just like
cyberpunk
everyone's asking for them i am jesus
christ pontius pilate will just fly
through a wall at you and you won't be
able to progress
he keeps sinking when he keeps walking
on water oh no yeah
what's up with the mechanics like i said
we're not making fun of the religion
no i think that's a great way to
i might contribute to this kickstarter
i'm going to link the kickstarter in
this video if you guys want to
contribute because i i
kind of want to see this come true what
do you think leave your thoughts down
below
merry christmas christmas keep a lookout
for a mandalorian reaction
see you guys